you know what I love about okay speaking
to family members or friends from the
Philippines versus just casually
speaking to friends here is that people
here don't have interesting stories like
I just got off at like a conversation
with my cousin Louisa and this is a type
of normal [ __ ] that she tells me she's
like oh yeah so one so separated from
her husband because she stabbed him with
a barbecue stick that's just casual
Congress I understand that over here my
friends are like oh yeah did you see
like you know the full moon and crystals
and [ __ ] like that on my own give [ __ ]
yeah barbecue skewer is a weakness to
liberalism that I don't like there's a
faction associated with leftist being
liberal oh my god totally leftist I
don't like it has to do with laying
where it has to do with also just in
terms of like I'm not a hippie I'm not a
hippie culture kind of a guy I'm more
the opposite I'm more like
counterculture what you say to me powder
called counterculture yeah that's true
counterculture did it feel good to
interrupt me and and and correct me in
that way during my podcast or no I'm
gonna ask you I'm not man I love you
bowels too how'd you train the bow I'm
telling you right now dude the day's
gonna come will remake robots you're the
you're the servant you're gonna be the
model that Emma was gonna want right
surrogate and you're your robotic parts
from the waist down are gonna be huge
I'm gonna magic that robotic we would
they would [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of this one
dijanna three yeah and we'd do John not
3000 oh yeah big [ __ ] right little
dick right but that you're also likely
you laugh at all the jokes during the
morning Saturday mornings with the kids
right then you want you know you want
you know what am i doing
cuz I give the robot so you were you
watch the Saturday morning cartoons with
ha ha ha ha
right what's not good no I'm trying to
listen your yeah you might not make any
sense I couldn't really keep up no yeah
I think that it's good you know big
better good thinks it's good question
that's all I give a [ __ ] about you know